you buy a truck for $60,000 to start a
shipping business the truck has a useful
life of three years you then have to buy
another truck so what I've done here is
I've drawn our actual a series of income
statements for our shipping business
this is year 1 year 2 year 3 year 4 this
is the revenue that we make in each of
those years so it's kind of a business
that right from the get-go we start
making $100,000 a year this is all in
thousands when we write it that way
so this is all in thousands so this is a
hundred thousand it kind of just stays
steady there we just keep making a
hundred thousand dollars a year in
revenue for the first 10 years and then
we have to pay a driver let's say that
the cost of the labor is $50,000 a year
so once again this is this is in
thousands and what I want to address in
this video so this would be a cost so
when you just subtract out the labor
cost you have 50,000 left and then your
other cost is going to be the truck
itself and what I want to think about in
this video is how should we account for
the cost of the truck so you might just
say hey look to start off I spent
$60,000 so in year one where I actually
go out to the truck store and buy the
truck why don't I just call it an
expense of $60,000 so one reality is you
could just say hey look in year one my
truck costs $60,000 then in year two I
don't have to spend any money on a truck
because I have one year three I don't
have to do it but then a year for my
first truck is now has to be scrapped
because I used it so much so year four
after buy another truck for $60,000 and
then again year five year six I don't
have to do anything then in year 7 have
to buy another truck for $60,000 8 9
don't have to do anything and then in
year 10 I have to buy another truck for
$60,000 so if you counted for the
purchase of your truck every 3 years
this way your profit would look like
this in year 1 100 - so this is revenue
in these two lines or expenses so 100 -
50 - 60 this is negative 10,000 of
profit in that first year second year
you make 50,000
earlier you make 50,000 just 100 minus
50 then 4th year again negative 10000
and then you make 50,000 and 50,000 and
then again negative 10,000 and 50,000
and 50,000 so to someone who looked at
this series of income statements they'd
say my god there's some kind of this is
some type of bizarre business in the
first year every three years you learn
of money I don't know why maybe it's
being mismanaged maybe something strange
is happening maybe it's because of bad
weather who knows and then you make a
ton of money then you lose some money
then you make a ton of money so it seems
like some type of very bizarre business
when you look at it from the operating
from the profit line just when you just
expense the truck every three years an
operating profit is the profit from the
operations before you think about how
you're paying for the operations how
you're financing them or or taxes or any
of that type of business but this is
strange because this is a very stable
business it's very strange for its
operating profit to kind of jump around
like this so the way that we kind of
reconcile this is by doing something
called capitalizing the expense of the
truck and then depreciating it over the
course of its life and I'll cover that
in the next video